Welcome everyone to today's well-being learning community webinar.
We're really excited to have you and really excited to learn
from the conversation that's going to occur today.
Before we get started, I just want to give some thank yous to all of our co-sponsors
and partners to make this possible, including the Department of Commerce,
the Federal Plan for Equitable Long-Term Recovery and Resilience,
the National League of Cities, New America, the Justice, Health,
and Democracy Impact Initiative at Harvard University, and the Well-Being Economy Alliance.
We've got a great event lined up for you.
We're going to start off hearing from the National League of Cities.
We're going to talk about the different ways that cities are innovating new approaches
to equitable well-being.
We're going to hear from Green Bay, who have a really interesting approach involving
private-public partnerships as a way to address systemic
and structural barriers to health and well-being.
We're going to have a discussion that will be led by Shannon Arvizu
from the Department of Commerce.
And then we'll hear from some other federal voices who are going to reflect and ask
and help us kind of process and unpack what we've learned.
And then we're going to close out with an audience Q&A.
So please do make note of any questions that come up as we're going through today's session.
This community comes out of last year's Census Bureau sprint on well-being measurement,
as well as out of the Biden administration convening on advancing equity
and well-being through data.
We've previously looked a lot at specifically federal efforts,
including at last month's webinar where we had a learning exchange with the Canadian government.
This month, we're turning the lens instead focusing on local efforts,
ways that cities have been leaders in the space of well-being or innovating new approaches.
As well as looking at and thinking about how federal agencies can support the leadership
of cities in a whole-of-government approach to well-being
at the center of our approach to public policy.
Before we hear from our guests, a word from a few of our co-sponsors.
First, I'll turn over to Amanda Janauve.
Hi. Good afternoon, everyone.
I'm thrilled to be here with you all.
So I'm Amanda.
I'm the economics and policy lead at the Well-Being Economy Alliance,
which is a global collaboration of organizations, academics, activists, and governments
that are really committed to redefining progress away from GDP or economic growth
towards centering social and ecological well-being.
And within this movement, we've engaged in supporting many federal-level governments.
But I think that a lot of the most exciting innovation we see, it happens at the city level
and can be such a huge inspiration for expanding our imaginations around participatory processes,
around more holistic whole-of-governance approaches, and really contextual strategies
that meet the needs of both people and planet in terms of the policy design and implementation.
So I'll hand it over to Elizabeth now.
We're really looking forward to the discussions today.
Welcome, everyone.
I'm Elizabeth Garlo.
I'm a fellow with New America.
And part of the genesis of this learning community is recognizing that there's just been this
tremendous groundswell of research and movement-led support to shift us toward well-being as a society.
And yet, we sort of lack the spaces to, with great candor and vulnerability, share
where we're getting stuck or where we're succeeding in implementation.
And so what we wanted to do with this learning exchange, as we did last month with Canada,
is just offer that space for us to dig a little bit beneath the surface, recognize
that we share conviction of the need to shift our systems in the direction of well-being
and really just sort of get underneath the surface and hear how things are working within
a particular context and foster this kind of unusual cross-section dialogue between our
federal stakeholders and local stakeholders.
So I'm going to just turn us right into the sort of heart of our discussion by bringing
in Sue Polis, who directs the Health and Well-being Portfolio for the National League of Cities.
We are so thrilled that Sue was open to collaborating on today's discussion.
Her work includes the design, development, and implementation of their Cities of Opportunity
Initiative, which is this multi-year effort to engage mayors and city leaders in comprehensively
addressing the social determinants of health through policy and systems change.
So I'm going to turn it over to Sue to give a little bit of an overview of her work.
And then she and her colleague, Gordes, will dive a little bit deeper with it.
So Sue, I'll turn it over to you.
Thanks, Elizabeth.
And it's wonderful to be with you all today.
Elizabeth talked about my current role at the University of the Health and Wellness
Portfolio for the League of Cities.
But really, prior to being at the National League of Cities, most of my work has been
on federal health policy and a little bit of economic opportunity work from my AARPJs.
So I really came to the National League of Cities with lots of questions around how
we could inform federal policy, but also how cities would be implementing this work on
the ground.
So just to say that.
And Elizabeth talked about the initiative that I've had the really humbling opportunity
to lead here and design and develop cities of opportunity.
And really, at its heart, when you kind of strip it all away, because policy and systems
change to address social determinants of health is a mouthful.
And it's really a matter of how do we support cities to bring them into this space?
So we designed cities of opportunity with a few really key sentiments.
Meet the cities where they are.
I spent a lot of time in my former role at Trust for America's Health developing
best practices, gold standards of different community-based models and interventions.
And candidly, not every city has the same capacity or the same ability to do that work.
And so really, meeting the cities where they are was sort of fundamental.
And social determinants of health.
Not mayors wouldn't say they would run on trying to address social determinants of health.
So how could we really begin to bring them into this work and space with the idea that
they do have a role to play in health?
And so we started talking to mayors and city leaders early on in my tenure here.
And really, they said there wasn't really one way or one key issue that they felt like they
could make a big difference in health as it's really a range of factors that impact health,
like access to housing or lack of access to housing, access to jobs or lack of access to jobs.
And so they were speaking to social determinants, but in a different way.
And since we knew people are not one-dimensional, they don't need one thing.
They don't need just a good school or just a safe home or just food or just transportation.
Our emphasis with cities of opportunity is really to help cities think about
the holistic needs of their residents in their community and work across
their city agencies, work more effectively in partnership.
And the city leaders also told us very early on that regardless of political party,
they felt like the zip code maps was a call to action.
And how a Democrat or Republican mayor might lead on a call to action could be different.
A Republican mayor that we spoke to said, for me, if I want my residents to work,
it's my responsibility to make sure they can get to work.
Transportation, more of the focus there versus other mayors that we talked to
you know, that might be more akin to health care access, right?
So very different, but all about reacting to those differences in what we call
quality and length of life, right?
Or social determinants of health, right?
The differences, sometimes 10, 12, 18 years difference in life expectancy
in neighboring zip codes.
And so those zip code maps really were so foundational to this work.
And so Elizabeth and Tony, as we were putting this together, asked me to just kind of share
some examples that have emerged as we continue to build cities of opportunity.
But also in our work over the last couple of years, we have been partnered with cities
to understand how they're moving into well-being measures, right?
How they're moving away from singular measures that have been used in the past,
like worst domestic product or GDP to a broader range of factors.
And we're seeing a lot of different ways the cities are coming to this work.
And so I'll try, we'll try to illuminate them for you today as part of this discussion.
But I think based on cities of opportunity and some of the examples I wanted to share
to kind of speak to some of the barriers we see, especially as we think about the role
of federal, state, and local partnerships, right?
To work toward alignment.
We've had some really wonderful work emerge through the cities of opportunity initiative.
We say wonderful because we feel like the work the cities are doing are transformational.
And I'll share a little bit about some of those with you.
So Tacoma, Washington was part of our Mayor's Institute on Economic Opportunity and Health.
And the real impetus for why is the health and wellness team
at the National League of Cities leading a Mayor's Institute on Economic Opportunity?
Because with the opioids epidemic, right?
Many cities were trying to think about how do we bring true recovery to our communities,
right?
Through jobs, through purpose, through giving people hope and seeing that they have a role
to play in their community.
And so jobs became a big emphasis of our Mayor's Institute on Opioids.
So we convened a Mayor's Institute on Economic Opportunity and Health with the recognition
that for some folks, it's really hard for them to even get into the workforce, right?
They might have a criminal record.
They might have an opioid use disorder or a substance use disorder, a mental health
condition, other factors, right?
And so with Tacoma, Washington, they already had a pretty good level of readiness.
They had their health equity index, and you'll hear a little bit more about that today,
that we're pointing them to the need to address economic opportunity.
They had an anchor institution partnership with their universities,
with their city and county representation, with their health stakeholders,
but it wasn't mobilized, right?
And so by working with us, we embedded data partner in all of the work that we do so that
the cities have that support because small and mid-sized cities in particular just lack
that ongoing data capacity.
And so what Tacoma really asked for was like, okay, we want a livable wage, we want livable
wage jobs.
What is a livable wage in Tacoma?
And we helped them do that analysis.
And the short story is it's $24 an hour, right?
And then the follow-on was now what sectors have jobs that can support $24 an hour wage,
right?
And it was the healthcare sector because of all of the job loss through COVID.
And so through that, a better understanding of what the opportunities and gaps were, they
really coalesced this anchor institution partnership around what they call the earn
and learn model.
And so what that is, is they're bringing people into workforce training, but they did
something really smart because we have a pretty big emphasis on civic engagement community
co-design.
They asked the community, what do you need to be successful in this program?
And lo and behold, it wasn't just the training, right?
But people have bills and other responsibilities.
And so what they were able to do was leverage the Tacoma Housing Authority, their county
workforce, WIOA dollars, the city's ARPA dollars, and these university partners to support the
job training and the healthcare sector to ensure that the jobs would be there should
they get people through the workforce training.
And so now that has spurred a more intentional focus, something that they can build on.
They're trying to build new cohorts of that earn and learn model to serve a greater number
of people.
They started in the Salishan community, and now they're thinking about what else can we
do to build more support for economic opportunity and addressing the racial wealth gap.
And so now they're really thinking about early childhood.
So you would say, well, that sounds reasonable, right?
But even though they had that partnership, the data was so fundamental.
And while you can have great sources of data, there's still more analysis and specifics
they need to really move through the policy, right?
And so I think Elizabeth and Tony wanted me to speak to some of the barriers.
Like Tacoma, everyone's trying to figure this out in every city across the country, right?
And so the reliance on federal funding streams for cities can be pretty high.
I talked about Tacoma bringing forth ARPA.
That's unprecedented that they would have that kind of flexibility to have skin in the
game to produce a pilot like this, right?
And so when we say more flexibility for cities, because often they're hampered, right?
Categorical funding streams from the different federal agencies often come with constraints
about how they have to be used and for whom and to what end.
And those differences in definitions, right?
Let's just take homelessness between the Department of Education, HHS, and HUD are
all quite different.
Even a city like Las Vegas that's implementing programs for AIDS patients, right?
Ryan White dollars and housing for people with AIDS dollars do not have matching definitions.
They have different criteria and it's very hard for them to even serve the same population
which those programs are intended to do.
So all of this trickles down, right?
Everything trickles down and so the burden is on alignment at the local level.
But then, right, people have to pull their heads up and say, is there a different way
to do this, right?
And so that's what we're really trying to help them do is set a table and move through
the work in a different way.
And I can provide additional examples, but I want to be cognizant of time.
Thanks, Sue.
Let's pause there real quickly.
I want to bring in Lourdes Aceves, who's the program director and the co-founder of
and a colleague of yours.
I think the two of you, it would be helpful to just hear a little bit about maybe just
double-click a little bit on well-being data and measurement and the way city and federal
stakeholders are working together in the Cities of Opportunity Initiative and otherwise.
And unfortunately, Chelsea Talbert from Tacoma, Washington isn't able to join us today to
do a kind of deeper dive on their equity index.
And so Lourdes, I want to invite you in to speak a little bit about those efforts.
Sure, I'm happy.
Can you hear me?
Yes, we can.
Great.
Yes, I'm happy to speak on behalf of Chelsea Talbert of Tacoma.
I hope she doesn't mind.
We've spent a lot of time thinking about the work in Tacoma as it relates to the Cities
of Opportunity and beyond.
But Tacoma was able to create an equity index.
And they created it based on feedback from the community who wanted Tacoma to be an equitable
and inclusive place.
And it came about in 2015 as part of the city's 10-year strategic plan, which now includes
an equity and empowerment framework.
And the challenge was that although the city adopted it,
city staff was challenged by how to lead with equity when performing tasks such as
installing streetlights.
They wanted to do it, but they were like, we're not exactly sure how that works.
So what the City of Tacoma did was in 2018, they worked with Ohio State's Kerwin Institute
to develop an opportunity index that evaluated census blocks based on 32
indicators in five categories to determine each census block or tracts, access to housing,
health care, and other amenities, as well as to determine low opportunity areas and
which communities were disproportionately impacted by the lack of access to these things.
Unsurprisingly, perhaps these were communities that were people of color, that were non-English
speakers, and so they created this opportunity index to give them that broad look at their
city, as well as to help them inform community engagement strategies and support the diverse
communities of Tacoma.
And as they shared with us, the purpose of these tools was threefold.
Is that a word, twofold, threefold?
We'll go with that today.
To identify and track disparities, to support data-driven decision-making,
and to increase transparency and accountability.
So what they, again, these are all wonderful reasons and goals, but they kept being challenged.
Well, how is city staff supposed to use these equity tools and indices?
So going back to the streetlights example, Tacoma only had a limited number of funds,
most cities, right?
That's the case everywhere.
So they had to prioritize.
And so to do this, they first assigned a safety score for each census tract, since safety's
key when it comes to public works, and then they applied the equity index score, which
resulted in some of the focus shifting to areas of lower opportunity.
The city of Tacoma also used these equity tools to distribute loans and grants for
small businesses, which I just love this story because they wanted to be fair, but they also
wanted to make sure they were investing in areas that historically had been under-invested
in.
So in 2021, 2022, they used a lottery system where everyone who applied received a lottery
entry, but businesses that were in lower opportunity areas received additional lottery
entries to increase their chances of securing a loan.
And the result was that 56% of the loans distributed in Tacoma during that period went
to BIPOC small businesses, and that was not the case in prior years.
So to me, this is a favorite example of how cities can measure and operationalize equity
using tools such as Tacoma's equity index.
So I just wanted to pause there because I was just providing a snippet on behalf of
Chelsea, and I want to give everyone else an opportunity to go.
Yeah, and I think just to take it a little bit into context about how cities are doing
this.
We would say it's still early.
It's still nascent.
It's more an outlier than the norm that cities are pursuing these types of efforts, and they're
all kind of similar and different, different as like Louisville uses a survey to collect
their information.
And I think you'll hear a little bit from Natalie and Joe today about how well it was
doing it through a survey-based approach versus Tacoma that's using more publicly
accessible data, GIS mapping, right?
So there's differences in how they're collecting it, differences in subjective, right, versus
objective, Tacoma's being more objective, getting a little bit more subjective through
the surveys, right, that Wello and Green Bay and Louisville might be doing.
So there are differences, and there's quite a big difference in how it's talked about,
like you'll hear Tacoma's equity index.
In Santa Monica, it was the well-being index, right?
They're all using slightly different terminology, but the result and the mechanisms are often
similar, right?
And so just wanted to kind of say there is some real differences in how these things look
and how they're coming to fruition and how different they are, right, in terms of how
they're guided by different data sets, right?
They're not uniform.
Thank you so much, Sue and Lourdes.
I think we'll pull you back in during our discussion where we dig a little deeper on
kind of federal-local collaboration, but that was such a helpful illustration of what you're
doing across the country in different places.
I'd like to turn it over to our friends from Green Bay, Wisconsin.
We have Joe Faulds, who's the Chief of Operations for the City of Green Bay,
and then we have Natalie Baumstad, who serves as the Executive Director of Wello, which is a
Green Bay-based nonprofit that's focused on advancing health and well-being for all.
So you have this kind of unique partnership here within Green Bay, both inside government
and outside in a nonprofit, and they'll share a little bit about the work that they've been
doing.
Thank you both so much.
Thank you so much for having us, and I'm going to go ahead and share my screen if that's okay
with everyone.
Can I just get a thumbs up, Elizabeth, that you're seeing that?
All right, wonderful.
Well, thank you so much for having us today.
We're really excited to be with you.
I wanted just to start off by saying, you know, we have a few minutes here with you today to kind
of share a little bit more about our approach here in Green Bay, but recognize that any one
of these slides, we could probably have a whole hour conversation or more with you all on.
So I would encourage you, if you do have questions, feel free to ask those at the end
of this presentation, and or feel free to, you know, reach out via email or a phone call.
We'd be happy to answer those questions for you and continue the conversation.
So again, my name is Natalie Baumstead, and I'll kick it over to Joe just to introduce
himself as well.
Yeah, I'm Joe Falls.
I'm the Chief Operations at the City of Green Bay.
So just like Natalie said, thank you so much for having us and letting us share a story with you.
Wonderful.
So Wello, what is Wello?
Wello is a nonprofit organization, and it's located in the City of Green Bay.
We were established in 2020 and have kind of an interesting kind of founding story.
Our local paper actually released an editorial asking people to think bold about what we could
do as a community to ensure a healthy, thriving future.
And the number one thing that readers submitted was around this idea of how do we invest in our
community's health?
And so much so that the paper actually brought then together a number of different partners,
partners from government, health care, business, educations, nonprofit, residents, and really
came together to think about what do we do with that kind of that community charge?
And the result of that was the formation of our organization, really recognizing kind of
meeting this backbone organization to really help create and kind of foster that bold and
shared vision around what does it mean to have a community well-being approach?
And our mission is really to co-create those community conditions that are fair and just
to drive high levels of health and well-being for all.
And we really recognize that one of the main issues that we have here locally is around
that that health and well-being inequities are really driving poor health outcomes for
people living in Brown County, Wisconsin, which is the county that Green Bay sits within
and really Northeast Wisconsin at large.
And that we know that for good health and well-being, we know that that's really a
fundamental ingredient for people, places, and economies to thrive.
And so Wello really is a part of this conversation by really addressing the systemic and the
structural barriers that are really limiting health and well-being.
And we use a kind of a grassroots almost equitable community building approach to achieve that.
So we started initially right in 2010.
We really started with this with this fairly large CDC grant.
So some of that public funding that really helped move and mobilize us.
But it was really focused on physical health.
And very quickly we learned that in order to really achieve our mission, we really needed
to think more broadly about what are all of those building blocks to really focus not
only on physical health, but more holistically on well-being.
And so through that process in 2015 and building into 2017, we really engaged on a strategic
planning process with our community that really started to to further spark this movement
and really be thinking about well-being.
And one of the things that we found is when we were focused on kind of that physical health
and obesity as part of that physical health conversation, we felt that many people
didn't really see themselves in that space.
It may have been not it's not very inclusive space.
And when we shifted the language around to one of well-being, we found more people
saw themselves in that that vision.
They saw themselves as part of the solution as well.
It might be that I'm struggling with my physical health, but maybe I have something really
great to give in terms of mental health or social connection or those environment pieces.
So broadening the definition to well-being really called more people in and allowed us,
we believe, to really spark a bigger movement.
When we looked at what do we need to sustain something like this?
One of the things that Sue mentioned is in Green Bay, we use a public-private partnership
in terms of financing this.
So what does that mean?
That means that we're not embedded within government.
We actually you heard me say that a CDC grant really helps spark the initial well movement.
So we do receive and we continue right for some of those public granting opportunities.
But then we braid that funding in with local, with state and other federal opportunities.
And in particular, given that we are founded with also in partnership with our health care
community, as well as our business partnerships, we also look at braiding in that funding to
really sustain these efforts.
And one of the things that we saw very concretely was the importance of having a backbone
organization to really continue to move this vision forward.
So because we are not embedded within a governmental unit, having that backbone that
can continue to really help cast that bold vision and then continue to really catalyze
some of the action around the actual work was really important.
And so as we continued our strategic planning process, we really wanted to be intentional
about thinking about how do we continue to support those operations and that core mission,
as well as really focusing in on that implementation science piece of the work.
So through that process, a number of things happened.
And one of the core things that happened was really this idea of defining what matters
to us and using local data to really think about what well-being looks like currently
and how it might change over time.
And so as we looked across the nation and across really the world at this time, so back
in kind of a 2017 timeframe, we were really looking at how do you define this?
What are those measures?
And really looking at what potential tools might be adapted to our local context.
And really the well-being equation that we prescribed to here in Green Bay is kind of
a two part.
One, it is really looking at how well-being is really a combination between personal
perspectives or their subjective measures, as well as those community conditions or those
objective data measures.
In Green Bay, we had relatively good local objective data, but we were in a data gap.
We were in a data desert when it came to those local subjective measures of well-being.
And so that's really where Wello focused to really work with a group to define what that
looked like, because we knew that that type of data would really help create the spaces
and really those conversations around which we could act.
And so as we fast forward through this strategic planning process, in 2019, we released our
first survey, and I'll go a little bit more in depth on what that looks like in a few
slides.
And then we really started getting to work.
So the data is all about how are we driving community-led projects, really focused on
bringing both those formal and informal leaders together and really also focusing intentionally
on the communications and storytelling and thinking about our audience as really the
community, right?
And how do we take what can sometimes be academic language and really focus on the community
facing language for that?
The other thing that happened here was on October 3rd, that is our official day of health
and well-being across our region.
So we had mayors of our two largest municipalities, so Green Bay and De Pere, as well as our Brown
County supervisor, all sign a declaration recognizing the importance of health and
well-being for our communities and for the future of our communities as well.
So at Wello, our model is kind of these, boils down to these seven key components.
So as we think about addressing structural and systemic barriers, often we get asked,
well, how do you do that, right?
And we like that question because at Wello, we really focus more on the how than in the
what, right?
We feel like that's really where that secret sauce lies.
And kind of the first thing that we think about is starting small.
You all live in this well-being world.
If you talk to someone about advancing equitable well-being, sometimes you get this kind of
this stare back at you, this blank look.
It seems so large, right?
And so when we think about how are we bringing people together and how are we
catalyzing action, we really understood very quickly that we need to start small.
We need to bring people along and we need to build those building blocks.
And so I often use the analogy of when you ask someone to engage with you on advancing
equitable well-being, it's like asking someone to come with you, just the two of you, and
try to boil the world's oceans, right?
It seems so unattainable and something like, oh my gosh, that seems so big.
How are we going to get our arms around that?
But instead, what if we said we have a glass of water right here, right?
We know some things about chemistry and biology and these different sciences.
How can we figure out how to boil this cup of water, right?
And what happens when we break it down into small incremental parts is that we're
developing a relationship with one another.
We're developing trust.
We're testing some things, right?
And as we're successful doing the small thing, we can then look at, okay, what's that next
step, right?
And what is that next step?
And that's really how you build sustained systems change over time.
So that is really kind of the heart of the work that we do here at Wellow.
We're always also identifying what is that win-win, right?
Why would someone want to do this with you?
And we're big believers, and you need to have a little bit of that win-win.
And that win-win may be because we can bring in some resources to help support you, and
that also supports the greater good, but you have to identify that win-win.
We also value and center live experience, as well as always leading with this entrepreneurial
spirit and really the spirit of innovation.
It kind of goes back to our founding around thinking boldly, right?
What is something that maybe we've tried and tried and tried again?
How can we think about that problem a little bit differently and try something new?
And at the heart of that, it's always learn by doing, right?
It's taking action and really resourcing that action so that we can build that local
capacity so that we can have the sustained impacts that we're looking to achieve.
So in terms of just some core pieces, one of those core pieces of how we do that work
is around measure.
So Wellow's measurement work, as I mentioned before, is really around a three-pronged approach.
So we recognize that there's inherent bias in just one of these approaches alone, so
we really bring in three approaches together.
One is that biannual survey.
So we do that on the odd years.
So we are coming upon a survey collection period here in July.
And then we also pair that with a panel study.
So that's a longitudinal panel.
It's about 600 people across our county, and it's really focused on the social
determinants of health.
And we actually use that vital conditions framework to really think about how things
change over time.
This was particularly helpful for some of our efforts as we thought about the pandemic.
So the pandemic hit, right?
And we had this panel, and we were able to ask similar questions about behavioral change
regarding how people felt in terms of safety, in terms of masking, different concepts like
that.
But we were also able to look at impacts to well-being.
And one of the things that we saw was while depression and isolation, those feelings of
loneliness increased, they increased at a greater rate for actually women than men in
our community.
So we're actually able to then think about, OK, what does that mean in terms of how we're
allocating resources for equitable recovery?
And the third prong of our approach is around ground truthing.
So really making sure that these first two approaches are point in time pieces.
And so how do we then also bring in some of that lived and learned experience through
our measurement team, as well as through community-led change projects?
And then in terms of activating that data, we also really are interested in how we
can kind of bring it into the digital realm and really think about and activate the power
of place.
So all of our data is collected currently by zip code.
And this next iteration of our survey will actually collect all the information by census
track.
And that is in a direct response to a lot of the federal and state-level data that is
by census track.
So we're trying to try to pair those pieces a little bit more intentionally together.
And then the second or third prong of our work is really around mobilizing and innovating.
And I think that's what makes our model a little bit unique, is that not only are we
measuring and holding that space to measure our progress over time, we're also able then
to really bring that into the advocacy efforts around how we really mobilize that data and
catalyze that data for change, and really bring it into innovative community-led projects
that can help really break it down and really focus the action to the small incremental
pieces.
So what have we learned?
What have we learned?
We have learned that system change, right, it really requires space for healing, trust,
and relationship building.
We think it is so important to focus more on the how and not necessarily the what, right?
And I think we often, especially in this kind of butt heads a little bit with how funding
usually is directed, which focuses on a category or a what, we really feel like in order for this
work to truly work long term, we need to focus more on the how and how we're building that
capacity.
The second piece of things that we've really learned is that the ability to have local and
equitable data ecosystems really matter, especially for a city like Green Bay where we're a mid-sized
community.
I think Sue mentioned this prior that we don't have necessarily a ton of operational
capacity to do this, but how important it is to have that local data because if we're
trying, if we're talking about systems change and trying to really disrupt these systems
and make them more equitable and justice oriented, we need data that's not lagging.
And, you know, Green Bay is the third largest municipality in Wisconsin, yet a lot of our
data that we have are lagging indicators.
And so it's really important that we do that.
And it allows us for us to have some of those challenging conversations that is rooted in
local data.
The third is really need investment in the core mission.
Again, because this really focuses on the how and not the what, focusing on that backbone
role is really important, especially as we think about unrestricted multi-year dollars
to really support the relationship building work that is required.
And we truly believe that starting small and aiming for those win-wins
really can't overstate that.
We always say like, think big, but start small.
And it really helps drive the proof of concept and bring more people to the table.
And with that, I know Joe has a specific example that he wanted to bring forward from a city
perspective on how we're kind of using data as well as mobilizing and activating people
for some change.
Yeah, I have an example of a real small win for Wello that I think went a long way in
building relationships with municipalities.
So in our area, we have a recreational trail that runs through several municipalities.
We also live in Green Bay.
We have something called ice and snow, which some of you I'm sure are familiar with.
So during the winter and sadly the spring months, sometimes the trail would not be
cleared off during all those areas where the municipalities, they own the trail.
So what happened was a neutral third party Wello really kind of brought those
municipalities together and said, what can we do to address this need so all of our
members of the public can use the trail throughout the whole year and during those winter months?
So they actually came up with an agreement together to share resources and ensure that
the trail would be cleared off throughout the whole year.
So it's a small win, but what Natalie has been saying is for Wello, it really built
some strong rapport with the municipalities.
And now municipalities can really look at Wello and say, we can rely on Wello to be a
trusted partner and really improving the health and wellbeing for our residents that we serve.
So really it's a small project, but it has gone a really long way for us.
Thank you, Joe.
I think at the end of the day, one of the biggest lessons is don't let perfection get in the way of
progress. And I've been fortunate enough to do this work in community for over a decade now.
And you often see, well, what's the measure?
What's the thing?
And have we thought of all of the things?
And I think that you're definitely a big believer in, you know, leading with intention and with
your values and making sure that those principles of equity and justice are central and that
community is central to the work.
And at the same time, recognizing that you're not going to have all the answers.
And so if we don't start, we don't start, right?
The only, you know, no progress is no progress.
And so I think we have really learned that in a beautiful way that our community has
come alongside us.
And we've been very vulnerable in the sense of here's the first iteration of our survey,
right? And we heard a lot of things like, well, why didn't you ask this?
Have you thought of this, right?
And then building that feedback back into the next iterations and working with community in
a really iterative way.
And I think in terms of how to build community well-being and resilience,
I feel very strongly that that iterative approach is going to be much more successful than
really having a top-down approach or, you know, trying to get to that perfect measure
because perfection is constantly one of those moving, moving stars among us.
So last kind of bit of information, when we think about sustaining the movement,
we worked in a very purple region, right?
And so one, you know, there's pros and cons of this public-private model that we have.
One of the pros that we think it brings is that we can, and we've kind of shown that
we can continue to push progress across political lines.
We've been able to kind of bring people together who may not usually come together around
some of these issues or may not be talking to one another.
And so I think it really speaks to sustainability across different decision-makers.
You know, when we started this, we had a different mayor than we have now, right?
And both of those mayors signed on to the declaration and both of them have worked
closely with us on really driving some of this work forward.
And Joe, I know that you had another example that you wanted to share
from a city perspective to this point.
Yeah, I think when it comes to, you know, sustainability and financing, you know,
I think Wello, as we've been mentioning all the time, that it has been the voice
and will continue to be the voice of health and well-being for the community.
And right now is really trying to use data to tell that story.
So from a funding perspective, you know, having grants or funding to, you know,
either to Wello or the City of Green Bay to further that data collection
is going to be critical because the data that is collected is providing the evidence
that we need to really drive policy change.
So, you know, Wello has shown, like the case I provided, you know, there's times
where Wello doesn't have data and, you know, it can create policy change.
So if we have the sustainable funding, Wello can really gather that evidence
and create even more of an impact in our community and drive more policy change.
Absolutely. You know, one of the one example that I'll leave you with here is,
you know, our city, we were able to, from that first survey, we were able to see very,
very discreetly the local challenges that we have and the gaps and the inequities that we have
racially for health and well-being outcomes. Right.
And that was something that I think often, you know, for elected officials or for city officials,
you can say, well, that's not an issue here. Right.
Or that's somewhere else. And to have local data sets that very discreetly showed that case,
we were able to have really great discussions in 2020 that resulted in the city really helping
spearhead an effort with Wello and a local health care organization to really declare racism a
public health crisis. And we did that collaboratively and brought on now over 17 other organizations
from across different sectors, because we truly felt like this issue is too big for one organization.
So how do we, again, together take this on, declare this as an issue that we need to take
more action around when we need to start that through this declaration. So that's an example
of how that data really helped drive really some of those conversations and some of those actions
moving forward. So we can talk a little bit more in the Q and A around some of the challenges.
I kind of listed some of the financing challenges with this model here, and I can provide that more
of an example of how we've worked through that with Wisconsin DHS. So we can save that for the
Q and A. But I think at the end of the day, one of the things I always think about on how to continue
to sustain something like this and this movement around equitable well-being is keep people informed,
keep them involved, keep them interested, and keep them inspired. So I leave you with that. And
again, this is Joe and I's contact information. We'd be happy to connect with all of you
offline or in the Q and A. So thank you for your time.
Thank you so much, Natalie and Joe. There are so many incredible nuggets in what you shared
to unpack, so I'm excited we'll have time for discussion. Just a couple of clarifying questions
that came in through the Q and A before we turn to my colleague Shannon for discussion.
One question is just, did Wellow have connections with the local government from the beginning,
or has that developed over time? Natalie, can you just speak a bit to how this relationship
got established? Absolutely. Yeah, so from the beginning, government was part of those
conversations. So I mentioned kind of the beginning with that group that really came together after
that editorial was created. So City of Green Bay and county government was a part of that process
from the very beginning. Wonderful. And then for our NLC speakers, is there a resource for cities
on best practices like here in Green Bay or ways to develop capacity to collect local data? Any
resources that you'd want to lift up Sue and Lourdes? And we can bring that into the chat too.
Yeah, I've reflected on this a little bit on local data. But, you know, it does depend on city
capacity, you know, like even something like EMS data, right, extracting that, putting it in the
context of other data sources. It's not something, you know, that most cities have the capacity
outright to do. And that tends to be an area where they have more partnerships, you know,
tends to be an area where they have more partnership, and it tends to be an area that
we focus on more in our cohorts so that we're embedding the capacity to support them.
Did that answer your question? Yes, thank you, Sue. If there are other questions or resources that
folks want to lift up in the chat, please do so. Then final just question before we turn over to
Shannon too, and then we'll have more Q&A time. Natalie and Joe, did you have any academic research
partnerships as you've been unfolding this work? Can you describe how those have worked?
And then I think this is kind of related to another question that's come up around ground
truthing with community members. So maybe just a little bit more on research partnerships,
in particular those related to ground truthing. Absolutely. So we really kicked this off with
two research partners. We have two institutions here, University of Wisconsin-Green Bay, as well
as St. Norbert College. One of the universities has what's called a Consortium for Applied Research,
and the other a Strategic Research Institute. And so we actually have a co-PI model that really
launched this work. And in particular, the panel study that I referenced, that is actually led
by the Strategic Research Institute at St. Norbert College, meaning they really are the
partner that helps us operationalize it. So because we're this nonprofit, right,
in this public-private partnership, we really wanted to find where are those opportunities
where, you know, with working with an academic research institute, they already have all the
data privacy, security, we go through IRB for this process, but we're able to flow that through a
group that does that day in and day out. And then we're actually able to then bring in the community
voices and thinking about what actually is asked and how do we do it, what are those methods,
those are informed by the well-owned community partners, whereas the academic partnership
does that. In terms of the ground truthing, great example, we've also worked with Medical
College of Wisconsin specifically around thinking about how we can further engage community members.
So when we think about community-based participatory action research, right,
thinking about how we can have our community members actually be researchers and really
empowering and shifting power in that way. And so we've actually piloted through one of our projects
that members from within the community have actually gone through the process of getting
city trained and are actually going to now be the researchers for that specific project.
But the idea is really thinking about what are those structures, what are those systems, and at
the same time we've been, you know, we've been working with Medical College of Wisconsin saying
this city training, how do we make this less complicated? Because if we want our
work to be community-led and we want it to be equity-based, why are we creating all these
barriers, right? We want to make sure that there are great protections for the data and that is the
utmost. But what are the things that need to be there and what are the things that maybe have
been there because, right? And can we push on those some of those structures?
Thank you both so much. So I want to bring in my colleague Shannon Arvizu, who's a senior advisor
with the Department of Commerce and has been spearheading a lot of work related to racial
equity and data. So Shannon, I'll turn it over to you to just have a chat, have a dialogue with
Natalie and Joe and draw out some further reflections, particularly as it relates to
federal local collaboration. Yeah, thank you so much and super inspired by what you all are
doing at Green Bay and examples of Tacoma as well, what the National League of Cities has done
to lay the groundwork for more movement building and capacity building. I really appreciate that
both of you, you know, both the National League of Cities initiative and what you are doing and
Tacoma is all about meeting the cities where they are. I think that's one of the things that
federal government can do better on. Oftentimes, when the federal government does produce
different versions of equity maps, that the intention of those maps is to look at the
broadest applicability. And one of the hindrances is that when those maps are ground truth, because
they oftentimes don't go through the very rigorous process that you all are doing to make sure that
it represents the voices of the people, that a lot of times those maps don't resonate and therefore
aren't very useful. And so I think there's some really great approaches that you all are highlighting
for us moving forward. In terms of specific questions, one of the things that I know all of
us here are interested in knowing is what are some of the most important ingredients that got
you to where you are today? You know, in terms of your leadership, certain types of funding, certain
types of internal capacity. I know you've touched upon a few of those, but if there's something else,
you know, kind of a pop open the hood, you know, kind of background maneuvering that you think
also really helped you be where you are today. I would love to know.
Absolutely. I'll let you start, Joe.
You sure? All right, I'll be quick. So, and I promise Natalie kind of mentioned this earlier,
but I promise I don't think my boss is on the line. But I do think having, you know, buy in from,
you know, the leadership, the city leadership, whether it's, you know, the mayor of Green Bay
really bought in other municipalities like Natalie said, and then also the county executive. So I
think when you get that buy in, especially in the public private partnership, you need the buy in
from the city leadership. And then I think what Wellow has done an outstanding job of is we talk
about starting small, but you have to build relationships along the way. And you're not
going to get it done just with Wellow partnering with the city of Green Bay or the municipalities.
They have to buy in and get buy in from private leadership too, which I think they've done an
outstanding job. So it's not just Wellow as a private entity and public entities, it's Wellow
as a private entity and the medical providers and any other private entity in that space too. So I
think it's really building the relationships and that takes time. And that's really what I think
Wellow has committed to. Thank you for that. Another question relates to, how do you think
some of this work is influencing decision making writ large for the city? I'm just curious if you've
seen now that you have this framework in place, are you starting to see what you've developed
being used as a filter for other types of niches that maybe aren't directly connected to what you're
doing, but starting to see some spillover influence? Yeah, do you want me to take that one,
Joe? I can kind of start. So really, I think interesting is, you know, when we started this,
I think a little bit, you know, you kind of you throw something out there, right? And, you know,
it was developed in partnership with our community, but there's a little bit of,
I hope, you know, I hope it takes hold. And I think one of the things that we have seen is
because of the different mechanisms we have in place, such as, you know, every year we have a
well-being summit, right? So it brings everyone together. Again, we talk about the data. If it's
an off data year, we talk about the action, the things that have been generated from it. It starts
to really, I think, you know, be that frame that people are using in their mind. And I think we've
seen kind of anecdotally how people have started using well-being more, have really talked a lot
more about equity, have really done a lot of internal work to think about what that means for
them, what that means for their organization. I provided that example around the ability to
really bring that whole city council together and unanimously vote to sign onto the racism of public
health crisis declaration. You know, using that local data was really instrumental in helping push
that forward, as well as to Joe's point, because we had a cross-sector group that was coming
alongside, it wasn't one group standing alone. It was, okay, now we have private business,
we have our education institutions, we have healthcare, we have public health, you know,
we have all these different groups that are standing together. So that helped, I think,
really catalyze that action. But we're also seeing it in small ways. So for example, our community
health improvement plan, you know, now is using some of these local data measures,
as well as using it in, so I should say our community health assessment is using it,
and then our community health improvement plan in some of those strategies, the strategies are
actually using some of these measures to really measure their success and really start to develop
further action plans with community. And then also you see things like the Asian American Resource
Center, or the Asian American Professional Association, that's really popping up and
emerging from our community using that data to show that there are specific inequities in those
populations from this well-being survey. We have other examples from the municipal equality index
at the city moving up because of different policies that are put in place to make sure that we have
greater representation and inclusion of our LGBTQ plus neighbors, right? So there's all of these
ripple effects that have been happening as a result of really, I think, this movement around
how are we ensuring that, you know, I think to the point that was made by Amanda earlier,
it's not just GDP. It is well-being. It is more broad than just those gross domestic product.
Love that. Congrats on the additional momentum that you're seeing there.
Also really appreciate the attention to the change management components of helping to make this stick
it looks like you have a very strong strategic perspective around that. And just kind of circling
back to the data side, especially as Elizabeth had mentioned, working with the Department of
Commerce where a census is housed, the EA is housed, we also have, you know, NOAA is housed
within the Department of Commerce, we have environmental data, economic data, associated
with graphic data, and we're always looking to see how can we better support states and cities
in the use of data for tracking, you know, and inspiring outcomes like the ones that you're
driving towards. Just curious, offhand, are there, if there's something that you think
or ways that the federal government can be a better partner with you in navigating some of
your data challenges, we'd love to hear any of your top of mind thoughts in that regard.
Oh, muted.
Geez, you think after however many years virtual now. Yeah, so I think, you know, again, we're
coming from kind of that mid-sized community perspective. And so, you know, I often say one
of the things that we do well here, and I have, I just have to say we have an absolutely amazing
team at Wello. These are a group of really, really dedicated community-minded individuals,
and I think part of the success of this, and I'll kind of go into some of the challenges with
the data, and it kind of dovetails off of this, is, you know, a lot of these things happen because
there was a group of people who wouldn't let them not, right? And I don't know how to, I don't know
how to bring that together in a way that, you know, it was very organic. We have a team that is just,
they would not let this not move forward. And when we thought about data, and we thought about our
limitations, it's, okay, how can we work with those institutions locally that have some of
that capacity so that we can build our capacity even though we know we have limited resources?
But I think, you know, from a federal perspective, you know, any opportunities where, you know,
whether it's capacity building that can be helpful for a community organization combined with,
you know, just some long-term unrestricted type funding, you know, one of the things
that really was an important ingredient to get us started was our local community foundation.
You know, we brought forward this idea of measuring local well-being and said we would
really like a multi-year grant to help make this happen, and they really saw a vision, and they
invested in it for three years at a, you know, a fairly substantial level. And I think
without that type of runway to iterate and to deform the partnerships and really test what
works, what doesn't work, because, you know, you can lay the best plans, but not until you do it
do you really start to understand what you need more. So I think from like a federal level,
really trying to understand how, with that capacity at a federal level, how can you support
those small and midsize communities in particular with building their local capacity, or even if
there's funding that can flow to help support those pieces, and even to the extent of being
able to do some of the analysis. You know, we recently were able to actually take in-house a
data and evaluation manager, and it has been transformational for the ways in which we've
been able to do more direct analysis and be more real-time with some of the things that we are
doing in terms of community-led projects and how we're integrating some of those different
data capacities. So, you know, while we have a great academic partnership as well, it's not
their full-time job, and so being able to then also have someone internal to that backbone
organization has really been helpful. So again, I think from a federal perspective, you know,
thinking about are there some financing mechanisms that could really be helpful, or some capacity
building mechanisms, because we would love to pair, like that second part of the equation is
really pairing those community conditions and those objective measures that are so beautifully
collected at a federal level. So how do we pair those together and make sense of them locally for
action? That's great, thank you. And since you mentioned funding and you mentioned ARP funds,
I'm curious about, you mentioned blending and braiding funds, and I was wondering,
can you just speak a little bit more? As we know, there are still opportunities for many other cities
to use those funds in the same way that you have, and that is one thing that we are interested in
focusing on for the next year, is how do we inspire more cities to use the funds in that way? So if
you could just speak more to how you went about blending and braiding and how you were able to
translate ARP to do the work that you're doing. Absolutely. Joe, do you want to speak to some of
those ARP funds from a city perspective first? No, you can start, I can fill it in. I guess the
only thing I'll say is, I was talking to Mayor Generich about this in the sense of, I think the
ARPA model, I think has shown to work really well with five different initiatives at the local level.
So I think from the federal level, if there's more health and well-being initiatives that the
federal level really wants to push forward, using the ARPA model to send funds directly to local
government can really work that way. Absolutely. I think here's an example I will bring forward is
how we've worked with our Wisconsin Department of Health Services. I had kind of mentioned that one
in the slide deck. Several, well, a couple years ago now, as they're kind of gearing up for
what would be coming down the line in terms of developing their budgets and different funding
mechanisms, we were able to kind of engage in conversations with them as a community-based
organization and really think about what were the goals and what were the values of our Wisconsin
Department of Health Services and how could community-based organizations help play a role
in that process? So it's not to say that we don't want to direct all our money to traditional public
health. I have a master's in public health and I love governmental public health, right? That is
a core area that we need, that has been underfunded and needs more funding. And at the same time,
how can we have that conversation as a state around how can we look at those dollars that
are available? And if part of our goal is to, again, drive equity and justice and have it be
community-led, then we need to be thinking about moving beyond, also moving beyond some of those
traditional structures and thinking about where are there places where community is doing a really
great job? And how can we move into more of a trust-based philanthropy model where maybe these
are smaller organizations with budgets 5 million, 1 million, 5 million or below, where a reimbursement
type model may not be something that those community-based organizations can actually go
after. So sometimes we have good mechanisms and we're trying to flow them to community-based
organizations, but the fact of the matter is a lot of organizations that are doing really great
transformative work may not be in a position where they should even apply or even think that
they can apply for that because say you have a large influx of dollars. Well, if you don't have
that capital on hand, and a lot of these organizations do not have large amounts of
capital to front that money to get reimbursed on the backside, right? So how can we rethink about
that funding mechanism? And maybe the reimbursement model is more of a, it's not a get rid of it all
together. Maybe it's a, you know, 50% is up front and the other 50 is based on reimbursement.
But really thinking about what is our intended goal and how do we, if we're saying we value
looking at equitable well-being and recovery, how are we then supporting those community-based
organizations on the ground doing some of that good work and encouraging that partnership between
traditional public health and our state and our federal government? The result of those
conversations is that as some of that, those dollars are coming through the CDC to our state,
you know, well, it will be in a position now to actually implement some of those projects.
We have a very specific project, you know, looking at heart health with our African American
population. So it's a great example of, you know, you have to be intentional about those conversations
at all levels. And so how can the federal government help provide direction to the state level so that
we're engaging in those local community-based solutions?
Thank you. Really appreciate all of your perspectives. I will pass it on back to Elizabeth.
Wow, that was rich. Thank you. We're going to move into a large group discussion in just a moment.
Before we do that, we have a couple of colleagues here from the federal plan,
the Equitable Long-Term Recovery and Resilience Initiative within the federal government, who
kind of in the spirit of these learning exchanges, we just want to invite folks in also at the federal
level to reflect on kind of core insights and takeaways and just, you know, share a bit about
what's happening in the federal context where you're situated that relates to what you've heard from
Green Bay and from MLC. So I will turn it over to, first I'll turn it over to Stu, who has the best
title of all time that I may not try. Stu, is it okay if I just turn it to you to share your title
because I'm pretty sure I might mess it up? Turn it over to you first. Yes, thanks so much. Yeah,
there's two months in there. So I'm the Acting Strategy Branch Chief and the Office of Strategy,
Policy and Requirements for one of the HHS operating divisions now. It's called the
Administration for Strategic Preparedness Response. So we really shoehorned the work strategy in there
or strategic at every level. But the work that we've been doing, and I can summarize that really
briefly, is just to say that we're the Preparedness and Response Organization for Public Health
Emergencies. So a little known before the pandemic, but now of course we have the Strategic National
Stockpile, the successor to Operation Warp Speed, now called HCORPS, all those different elements.
But what I want to really reflect on is just how great it was to hear these examples
for how this resilience framework is at work. And I'm giving just my perspective sort of as
an analyst perspective and some of the conceptual underpinnings that we saw in when I first saw the
well-being framework. And it was really well highlighted in the recent Health Affairs article
that talked about it as sort of differentiation from the social determinants of health was that
it was positively stated and that it sort of borrows from the human services sort of wing of
the house, which always goes to no wrong door. And so no matter which way you come from the vital
conditions, you can contribute to the whole of resilience. And so for me, I really saw that as
sort of reflecting coming to it. Now, you know, ASPR has highlighted community resilience. It was
one of the major themes of the 2014 National Health Security Strategy. And in the recent
update that just came out a couple of months ago, it was highlighted again,
community resilience and health equity. Certainly seeing that as something that underplays
national health security. But it sometimes can be a little bit qualitative or descriptive. But when
we get to the statement of all people and all places thriving, no exceptions, that really,
I think it has a sort of coherent element that gets many diverse players from so many different
walks of life able to contribute to this whole. And just to reflect on that, I've also had a
background in homeland security and there for risk, for example, is completely negatively stated.
It's threat, it's vulnerability, it's consequence. It's all about things you want to avoid. And yet,
when we look at resilience, and our office also worked on the National Strategy for Resilient
Public Health Supply Chain, we wanted to make sure that we stated it positively. It's a leap
back or towards an original popular condition. But in some ways, it's more than that. It should
be more than just an identification of making whole. It should be about leaping forward. And
so that is what I think I really was happy to see that getting away from some kind of
concept of resilience is sort of resist, absorb, adapt, recover. Those are also important things,
but they're not generative in their outcome. It's all still in relation to some shock
when we have to resist or respond against. In contrast, this well-being framework is
conceptually and practically allows us to square that circle. So it's an all-encompassing term that
allows us to talk about a constructive resilience that allows for sort of a comprehensive nature
and a positive aspect towards resilience being something that we can all build up
towards these better conditions. So that was really, I think, galvanizing. And as you go,
you'll see on the federal plan, there's a number of tools. There's a visualization tool to show all
the various organizations in the federal government that can contribute to this. There's the resources
mapping tool. I think it's over 500 programs and activities. So being able to see that
the ability to affect the whole through the cards, I think, was really important. And so I just want
to briefly say that we have a growing number of implementation opportunities across the federal
government in partnership with the private sector and our SLTC partners and supporting the federal
plan. And it is a 10-year plan. So we're seeing that as a longer arc as well. And that really,
right now, our work is on implementation and developing an analytic measurement that can
support sort of a broader systems level measurement to how we could look at those things.
And just really excited to hear the work that's happening across communities and moving us
towards thriving. And we just welcome the opportunity to keep building partnerships
together and better understanding. So I'll stop there. I can say more, of course. But I just
definitely want to hear from Laverne. Beautiful, Stu. Now, if there are more comments or questions,
we'll circle back to you in a discussion period. But thanks for lifting up that article. I dropped
a link in the chat for those who are interested, as well as a link to the ELTR plan that Stu was
just talking about. Laverne, I'm going to turn to you and your work in the National Institute of
Health. Just share a little bit about kind of what you're taking from today's discussion and
how it relates to the work you're spearheading. Sure. Thank you, Elizabeth. So I, like Stu,
was very inspired by some of the comments and discussions that took place today. I think of
well-being a little bit different from Stu in that I think that well-being, resilience,
risk mitigation, risk reduction, all of those things are complementary approaches so that we
can achieve thriving. We can't achieve a thriving society unless we have someone making sure that
we're reducing the risk and mitigating those adversities. And then there has to be a well-being
piece. There has to be an opportunity to enhance well-being. And then there, we have to be prepared
for resilience, right? We have to know that when that stressor or shock comes that we can recover
from it in an appropriate manner. And it's those things together that lead to resilience. I'm sorry,
that lead to thriving. But what was interesting about what was spoken on today, I thought it was
going to be all about data, data, data. Like everybody did say, you know, we are collecting
this data. We're now collecting the opportunity index and that data there. And I looked at the
link about what's going on, how you're looking at your equity overview at Tacoma, Washington.
But it wasn't really just about the data because when you think about it, even the opportunity
index, you probably already had that data just in a different stance when you looked at your
social determinants of health. It probably, probably the same areas on that map were highlighted
when you looked at your social determinants of health versus your opportunity index versus
your equity index, probably saw those same groups of neighborhoods highlighted. But what was
interesting, I think, what was different now, I think, is the trust that I think that Natalie
spoke about. She said they had healing, trust, relationship building. I think that was key
because I kept asking myself, okay, so what's different about this data? Did they ask different
questions? Are they pursuing it differently? There must be some nuance that's different about
this data now. And yeah, I think there probably is some nuance and I was hoping that you all
would address that during the question and answer part. But I think even more important,
I think the success really is coming from that building of trust. I think you wouldn't have had
conversations like racism as a public health crisis if you had not built that trust. And I
really would like to know more about how you were able to achieve that because I think that's key.
And I appreciate the comment about the funding mechanisms because I think that's something
especially at NIH that is so important because we might have the best ideas in mind. We might have
the best hopes in mind when we come up with these fundings and we're saying, listen, we're going to
fund these communities so that we can uplift these communities. But then they don't have access to
the funding. We're saying, oh, it's there, but they're not using it. At least that's what I hear
all the time. We're providing these grant opportunities, but they're not using them.
So what can we do? If they can't use it, they can't use it. And I really appreciate how clearly
you articulated that. Some communities, you're telling them you're going to reimburse them.
Well, how are they going to spend money that they don't have to be reimbursed? That makes so
much sense. And so I really appreciate that comment. And I thank you again for
allowing me to participate on this. Thank you so much, Laverne. We did have a question come
in for the two of you. So, Stu, I'll prompt you first. And Laverne, please be able to jump in as
well. Just a question about this 10-year federal plan. It seems like it centers long-term thinking.
The question is really how do we ensure the continuity of this long-term thinking,
especially across political administrations and cycles? So could you share a little bit more
about what's at the heart of that plan? Well, yeah, I think Natalie said it well
when she talked about starting small. And that I'm a fan of just continuous improvement. So you
get started, you see the impact, and then you do whatever it is you're doing a little bit better
and work towards that. It is part of the federal plan over the course of these next 10 years.
And so for me, it was really a light bulb moment to talk about how basic needs for transportation
could affect health outcomes. So coming in from HHS, I'm not going to necessarily think
first about transportation, but there's all these inroads towards thriving that work towards that
whole. But that's why I think it's important to have it published as well to speak towards making
sure it's really sustained over longer term. There are these programs that you wouldn't think
otherwise do contribute to these overall thriving and resilience goals, but they do.
And so first being able to see that whole and identifying it, I think it's an important element
to being sustained and maintained. And I think Aaron's leadership, I think the fact that
we have started to see buy-in from every agency and the way that Aaron has brought these groups
of people together and people are saying, yes, we're going to change this system or we're going to
change this mechanism, adapt this policy. It's like once you get the ball rolling, it has momentum
of its own. And I think Aaron has done a great job of bringing the right people together
to get the ball rolling in so many different pieces or areas of the federal government
that in my opinion, you're not going to be able to stop their ball from rolling.
Even if a new administration comes in, that ball is going to keep rolling.
Wonderful. Thank you both so much. I'll turn it over to Tony for discussion.
Yeah, thank you everyone who's already shared. To let folks know, you can add more questions to
the Q&A and there can be questions to any of the speakers that we've had throughout this session.
I want to just elevate one question that was brought up in the chat a little earlier. That
came from Elias who's asking about, we've talked a lot about how we can empower these local communities
to better leverage and these federal funding streams. And Elias was wondering how more cities
might extend opportunities to their community organizations to exercise a greater degree of
economic participation. And so I know you did some answering the chat, but do you or anyone else who's
speakers from the call just want to touch on this of how potentially funding could be better
used to kind of elevate the power of community organizations in their economic participation?
Yeah, I would just say over the last few years, especially with COVID, public trust in government
is so low, maybe at an all-time low in some places. And I think one of the great recognition
of city leaders is there's a really great level of inquiry and great level experimentation
on what we call community engagement to community co-design. And we've done a couple of forums just
with our cities of opportunity cities about some of the ways that they've really gone about
doing this, right, to really center community and what their needs are. And so from Rochester,
Minnesota to Birmingham, Alabama, to a variety of different cities, they're really
trying to move this needle. And the American Rescue Plan Act was unprecedented amount of
funding to cities. I think we all acknowledge that. And it really did provide the flexibility
to do some things that cities haven't been able to do that easily in the past because of constraints
of how they can use their budget. So I use the example of Rowan Oak, Lourdes shared that right up,
but one of the interesting things in the way they use their ARPA dollars, they really had
trouble getting the community to the table because there was a lot of skepticism that
something would change. And so one of the things that Rowan Oak really did was do something the
communities had been asking for for a long time, which is repair broken sidewalks and street lights
to show some good faith that things could be different. And I think now they've continued
to sort of build on that multi-sector engagement. In Tacoma, it was really through a community-based
organization that really drove the community engagement and feedback on their earn and learn
model. But there's a range of different approaches that cities are using. And it is a lot of
different methodologies in different places, which I think points to when we talk about efficiency
of scale, I think one of the speakers was saying, I thought this was going to be all about data.
It's really the data to drive the decision-making. That's what we're after.
So centering the data in the decision-making. And I think that's really what we're after here
and really trying to help the cities. And I think for federal agencies, every city that
starts a multi-sector partnership, the first thing they want to do is a data sharing agreement.
And the constraints, HIPAA, FARPA, over and over and over again, reinventing the wheel
in every community. If there could be some coalescing of even just technical assistance,
navigating this, because they all have to go through their own process every time in every
discrete case. There's really no efficiency of scale to really move through this. And then I
think Natalie made several great points, but I think on the research and evaluation, scale what
works. But a lot of cities don't have the capacity to evaluate their own programs, which
we've seen on a whole level of issues, including opioids. Where are your overdose deaths? Where
are your programs? What are the programs getting efficacy? What could you scale? It's really hard
for cities to answer those questions, so we point them to academic partners. But the feds have spent
so much money, even just in these last couple of funding cycles on mental health and substance use,
yet there's no infrastructure to support how you can tap some of that toward research and evaluation.
Thank you, Sue. I really wanted to echo that point. It's kind of a
question of analysis in program design, is really thinking about how are we making cities reinvent
the wheel, and how can we design this program, this funding stream, in such a way that really
empowers cities to not need to reinvent the wheel. So I think that was an incredible and
really important point that Sue just made. One question, and this could be answered by Sue
Lourdes, or especially wanted to hear from Natalie and Joe on this, do cities have an interest or
use in county-level data? There was discussion here about data at the zip code level, at the
census track level, but one of our audience members asked, how can those of us who use
county-level data best work with and make our data useful for cities?
Natalie or Joe, do you want to start, and then I can?
Yeah, absolutely. Yes, is the short answer. I think the county-level data is also very,
very important. So I mentioned a little bit that I say loosely that our geographic
boundary is Brown County, Wisconsin. We're in a unique position here where we have,
what, 24 municipalities within Brown County. And honestly, on my drive to work in the morning,
I only have a 10-minute drive, but I go through three municipalities. So these are imaginary
lines that are drawn. And when we think about well-being and equitable well-being and recovery
and all of the things that go into creating thriving people, economies, and places,
it's really important that we're thinking, like for us, especially like county data is really
helpful because you may drive through three municipalities. We're all in the same county,
but it's important to be able to then distinguish those smaller units when we're thinking about
allocation of resources. But I would say it is very important to have county-level data as well.
And you can see also then where there's some additional analysis you could do to really
understand compare and contrast between zip code, census tracts, and then county-level. And I think
that there's some really interesting things in terms of how you make decisions and how policies
would be set. But especially, I think, from a county-level, and if there could be county-level
policies that could move this work forward for all of those municipalities within the county,
that would be very, very helpful. And so to that end, I think that county data is also very good.
And that's why the measurement that we do here locally, while we break it down by census track,
we do that analysis for our county. Yeah. And I would just add, you know,
we're co-located at National League of Cities and the National Association of Counties. We're
co-located to try to spur really greater collaboration. And, you know, there's
very distinct but very essential roles where we try to really foster city and county
regional approaches. And often the counties might have a better level of resources,
better level of data. So it is very fundamental to, you know, and in some places, right,
like Tennessee, they've consolidated city-county government, and there is some better ability
to share across city-county. But in most other places, right, they've got to,
where it's not set up that intentionally, they really have to work at that relationship building
and really trying to bring those things together. And, you know, we try to foster that.
As much as we can because of the value, especially serving across municipal boundaries,
but within a county, which I think is what Natalie's pointing to.
Last question is for Joe and Natalie, about 30 seconds each. If you received a phone call
from another city who wanted to do what you've done and you, you know, one piece of advice to
help them in that journey, what would you recommend? And we can, Joe, we can start with you.
Sure. And going off of what Natalie and Sue just talked about, you know, if you're a lot like
Wisconsin and pretty unique and you have tons of municipalities, public-private partnership is
probably the best way to go about it. But if you're a bigger city, then you probably want to try and
get it in-house a little bit. So I think that's, you kind of got to look at your area and assess
what would be the best fit for that. But I think what we said all along, it's really about starting
small and getting those small wins and building up that momentum. That's the first thing, I think,
to get started and really kind of helped us out. And I think it will help out anyone.
Thank you. Natalie?
Beautiful. This is a great question. And I feel like, oh, what's the answer here? I think one of
the things that I always come back to is well-being is about people. And so thinking about who are those
formal and informal leaders, and in many cases, it is the neighborhood associations, right? It is the
folks who naturally are organizers within our communities that are really going to be those
folks who are the early adopters to this framework and can help bring others along. And I think it's
so important to really drive and center people in all of this work, because it can get really easy
to bog it down with this framework or this measure. And at the end of the day, I always like to bring
it back to this is about helping support and create opportunities for all people to thrive.
And so how are we continuing to center people and leave that door open to engage all people
in the conversation? Wonderful. Thank you very much. I'm going to turn it back over to Elizabeth
to take us home. Great. Well, I just want to extend a huge thank you to our speakers. There
were some really resonant themes. We heard a bit about the nuts and the bolts of this work, but
ultimately it's about thriving economies, people, places. As Natalie mentioned, it's about people.
It's also about our planet. I noticed that just recently the Biden-Harris administration announced
$575 million in grants through NOAA to support coastal resilience, right? And so we know that
the ecosystems in which we are part are counting on us to do this work. Flexible multi-year funding
is crucial in this work. It sounds like there's just so much that can be learned from the use of
ARPA funds that we can continue to surface and exchange around. Partnerships really help address
some of the capacity challenges and barriers inside local government and that we have to start
somewhere. We can't let perfection be the enemy of getting going in this very important work.
I'm going to ask my colleague, Amanda, to just share a little bit about some of the next steps
that she sees around federal and local stakeholders. Sure. Yeah. And I realize we're at time,
but I want to just really hone in on the point that Natalie really made about the importance of
how over the what. I think in our experience working with a lot of different governments,
I would say most OECD countries now have some sort of wellbeing indicators, frameworks,
but the difference between whether or not it gets stuck there or it actually transforms into
meaningful reformations in terms of decision making and processes is a lot about that point
of moving at the speed of trust and having broad-based support and engagement. And so
this is one for the federal government. We all is really about trying to build the movement,
a multi-stakeholder coalition. And so ask what kind of support do you need to feel like the work
that you're doing is really going to be backed by society and a wide range of actors in order to
feel like that's sustainable. And then at the city level, I think there's a huge amount of really
exciting innovations that are looking at new types of deliberation, decision-making process,
and also strategies that try to bring together things like participatory budgeting, community
wealth building, circular economy, and all of these different strategies together. And so if
there's ever any interest in connecting with other cities globally, or we can provide some
experiences from our sort of piloting with cities around the world in this work,
love to offer that and really look forward to our next discussion. Thanks.
Thank you, Amanda. So we'll be sharing out a recording of the discussion. We'll include
the tremendous amount of resources that were serviced in the chat. And just know that this
is the second in a kind of learning series that we're really hoping to continue cultivating where
we can exchange on these ideas, certainly across different levels of government and with the many
allies and partners we have in communities around the country. So thank you for your time,
and hope you all have a wonderful rest of your day. Take care.
Thank you. Bye-bye.